this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi and this is the
Cornell turfgrass video log and we're
talking seed heads today not so you had
suppression but what happens when you
start to get the seed head breakthrough
so the annual bluegrass eventually will
start to see doubt eventually break
through the PGR suppression that's done
every spring and as a result you'll get
a natural decline on the other side of
the seed head production the seeded that
is produced on that tiller spells the
demise of that teller that tiller will
die and then you'll get a natural
thinning this is also a very common time
where you see a little bit of a setback
in the annual bluegrass a sort of
reshuffling of energy away from root
growth away from energy production as
the plant makes the shift from
reproductive back to vegetative growth
so be careful at this time not to over
stress especially if you come into any
heat periods that you want to be really
careful about really putting the grass
under stress it is a good time to do
some vertically if it's cool good time
to do some spiking take advantage of the
cool weather but if we get into any
stress periods recognize that the annual
bluegrass is under stress because of the
seed heads waning and that could be an
ideal time for things like basil rod
anthracnose to rear their ugly head so
be careful at this time of year
recognize the biological shift that's
going on in annual bluegrass and you
should have an excellent start to the
growing season
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu